par deux fois la commission des finances
de l'Assemblée nationale a adopter la
première partie du projet de loi de
finances pour 2023
des débats se sont tenus dans
l'hémicycle en première lecture et le
texte a été adopté enrichi par des
propositions de la majorité comme des
oppositions
un examen complet de cette première
partie du projet de loi de finances a
également eu lieu au Sénat
cependant alors que commence la nouvelle
lecture de ce texte de constat s'impose
à nouveau à nous
d'une part comme je l'ai déjà dit la
France doit être dotée d'un budget au
1er janvier prochain
c'est la raison pour laquelle l'examen
du projet de loi de finance est encadrée
par des délais constitutionnels or notre
temps de débat a été raccourci par le
dépôt systématique de motion de censure
et nous devons avancer
nous devons permettre l'adoption du
texte dans les délais impartis
d'autre part au moment où l'examen de ce
projet de loi de finance commence en
nouvelle lecture aucun des groupes de
position nous nous a fait connaître une
évolution de sa position sur son vote
finale
aussi sur le fondement de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution j'engage la
responsabilité de mon gouvernement sur
la première partie du projet de loi de
finance pour 2023
le texte que je vous soumets aujourd'hui
reprend largement celui qui a été adopté
en première lecture
c'est néanmoins comme à chaque fois un
texte enrichi par le travail
parlementaire
ainsi nous avons retenu plusieurs
dispositions votées par vos collègues
sénateurs notamment en supprimant la
condition d'âge de décès pour que les
veuves des anciens combattants puissent
bénéficier d'une demi-part fiscale
il s'agissait d'un amendement porté par
la commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat
par les groupes les républicains et RDPI
en conclut en concrétisant également le
financement de trois grands projets de
LGV il s'agissait d'amendements
socialiste ou encore en prolongeant le
crédit d'impôt en faveur des bornes de
recharge électrique privée il s'agissait
d'une mesure portée par le groupe
centriste et le groupe RDPI
enfin et c'était une mesure attendue une
mesure sur laquelle je mettais engagé
devant les maires de France nous avons
fait évoluer le filet de sécurité
protégeant les collectivités locales
face à la flambée de des prix de
l'énergie en le simplifiant et en le
rapprochant du dispositif voté au Sénat
[Applaudissements]